[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka bada ditch
cumberbatch
and this video we're breaking down
episode 12 of the bad batch
what's han solo's favorite rapper tupaca
it's it's the way i tell him now the
show is in its final quarter
and it's been a blast from start to
finish in this video we're going to be
breaking down the ins and outs of the
latest release
including its easter eggs hidden details
and hints towards the biggest star wars
canon
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then i
highly suggest that you check
out now like the video then thumbs up
you click
and subscribe you will if you think
channel good is
so bad but thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the bad batch
okay so last week we traveled to ryloth
to see the empire's aggressive expansion
in full effect senator had decided that
he and the twilights would be better
under their rule
and after his first appearance in attack
of the clones he's pretty much been in
place to represent the corrupt greed of
the senate
the last episode very much laid the
seeds for the origins of ghost
and put the pieces in place as to why
hera would end up joining the rebels
there were lots of comments last week
about how hera had dropped her accent
and i kind of feel like this was put in
place to show the distance between her
and her father
in rebels we learned that after the
death of her mother that the pair became
estranged because he went off to fight
the imperials on other systems instead
of just focusing on ryloth
however there was a moment when she did
go back to her accent to plea with him
and she's one of the more interesting
characters in the series even as early
as this in the canon
she's starting to question and resist
the imperials
and the episode followed her as she went
with gobby glee to collect weapons from
the bad batch
it ended with rampart framing champ for
the attempted assassination of senator
and that should be you fully caught up
now occurred to the episode titled
rescue and ryloth and we start off with
the planet looking slightly different to
how it was last time
in the previous episode it was bright
and sunny whereas here a darkness reigns
over it
showcasing the empire's new occupation i
absolutely
love it when star wars does subtle
things like this and this idea of a
shadow encompassing all hawkins back to
a new hope
and it was also repeated last week when
herrera was sitting looking at the
clouds
later on in the episode he watches probe
droids roam the crowd with gunships
pointing at the population
and it's a stark contrast from what we
saw last week we see that charm and co
are now in prison cells which look very
similar the ones that cadbane had on his
starship
the shield doors also look a lot like
the ones that we saw at the end of the
phantom menace
just before qui-gon became qui-gon
hey now we hear the french accents in
full effect once more
and shout outs to simon a birming on
twitter for pointing out that this was
put in place
by george lucas i know some of you hate
when i go off and do my war comparisons
but potentially this is to mimic the
french resistance
who were of course one of the largest
rebellions in the second world war
they're called insurgents have points
but the imperials forget that this
is their home and that they are the
invaders rampart threatens cham and his
daughter
and this clearly irks hauser quite a bit
last week a lot of you said that you
think he's a clone whose chip didn't
activate fully
and that he still retains a lot of his
free will this definitely could be the
case and though we don't get it
confirmed in this episode
it's clear that he has a moral compass
and will question orders if they involve
killing innocents
he knows that it wasn't charm or his
forces that shot
and he won't tar his supporters with the
same brush
rampart pretty much threatens him with
exposing this info
and the imperials clearly want to take
down any insurgents
great little touch here as well as the
crates we see being moved around by the
troopers in the background
look a lot like the weapons crates that
the bad batch handed over last week
on the outskirts of her home hera has
closed in and she sees that the elite
squad led by crosshair are hot on her
heels
they haven't recruited another member
since crosshair killed the last one
and i'd love it if one by one they got
picked off in the rest of the episodes
back with the batch and mega makes their
droid gonky go wonky
when she tries to fix his power unit
which we learn is defective
this is a nice little nod to how
everyone in the batch is defective
but that doesn't mean they're bad on
paper crosshair is the only one doing
what he's supposed to
and no one likes him anymore nobody go
on the dislikes there if you still like
him
you sucker also is it just me or is
crosshair's voice getting creepier and
creepier the guy sounds like a cross
between the emperor and mr burns at this
point
and he's all like we must hunt down the
batch
now i know this theory is flying about
that his chip didn't actually work
either
and that he just went with the empire
because that's what he believed the
galaxy needed
i would love this twist and at this
point i almost feel that he's too far
gone
hera reaches out to omega and though the
message isn't verbatim to what leia
delivers in a new hope
the position and the way that she's
playing definitely follows
a similar sort of pattern again it's
like poetry
it's sort of it it happens over and over
again so that easter egg hunters can can
point it out in in bad videos like this
now i love how the batch
shoot down the idea at first but omega
is the one who steps in
and tells them what to do she's really
starting to have her own input
just as much as the rest of the group
and thus they journey back to ryloth
here they come face to face with chopper
and hera and they want the batch to free
her parents from the capital
a little bit of trivia yeah chopper is
actually voiced by dave filoni
who right now is doing god's work and
also chops work
anyway we also see how the empire are
using lies and propaganda to make the
twilight's turn on cham
and it makes me wonder what would happen
if tar woke up and just told everyone
what had really happened
i really don't know as he is after power
so maybe he would potentially still
throw cham under the bus anyway
tech mentions that there's as many
forces as there were on raxis
which of course appeared earlier in the
season a probe droid catches them and it
sends out a signal similar to what
happened at the start of the empire
strikes back
this alerts crosshair and its own
the hunter destroys this by hitting the
central eye which we learn in revenge of
the sith was the quickest way to take
down a droid
spooked by it the batch want to bail
organa but a mega guild trips them
even though the probability of survival
is less than two percent
probably now back with cham hauser
promises to protect hera
and it becomes clear that he was the
clone commander on the planet during the
clone wars
this adds a lot of way to why he's been
wrestling with his orders and hera and
carl form a plan to break out her
parents
i love how the second episode sort of
becomes a jailbreak one
and hunter also realizes the kids are
all right he decides to allow them to
come on the mission
and we join them at the dunya mining
facility as we mentioned last week this
material was used to build the death
star
and it's clear that this is what the
imperials are actually after
rather than the peace and prosperity
that they promise omega also refers to
the batch's her brothers
and this is of course because they were
clones but beyond that
brothers is also used in the military to
call people a band of brothers
because of the bond that soldiers share
chopper stealthily sneaks into the base
and hacks their system using his power
charge arm
which we've of course seen being burst
out by r2d2 at several points
it can be used to control tech points
and please the ladies
as it pushes all the buttons
unfortunately chopper is caught
and it's on omega and hera to go save
the day the pair hijack a shuttle
and this gives hera a chance to show off
her piloting skills
hera would of course go on to become one
of the best pilots in the rebel alliance
and she was last seen in the game star
wars squadron by
ea she's in the game elsewhere at the
batch scale of war
that's really bad now elsewhere the
batch scaler wall and you know i'm quite
proud of that one
now elsewhere the batch scale the walls
of the facility and hera helps not only
to destroy the parts of the refinery
but she also buys them a distraction
they launch a small assault and we see
the cannons that were too present
on the death star and pretty much every
star wars game ever
rampart isn't too happy and hauser ends
up being put in charge of guarding the
capital
the batch rescue the twilights and
crosshair sits with his sniper ready
whilst the elite squad close in before
they can be ambushed though
hauser arrives and saves the day by
warning them
of the incoming carnage hauser gives a
speech to his brothers
and attempts to get them to rise up and
stand against the imperials
it actually works and some lower their
shields and weapons
showing that the clones still have free
will the distraction buys the batch time
to escape
and i love how hauser and crosshair
mirror one another as they both look up
at the ship
here are two brothers where one has done
the right thing whilst the other has
done the wrong thing
and it's nice that they reflect each
other and show the dichotomy of their
characters
hunter turns down the money and though
not fully intentional
the batch are once more helping to build
the rebellion this money will be used to
arm up and resist the imps
and it shows just how selfless that the
batch are tech shows hera how to
scramble a ship's signal
and they slip off into the stars now we
didn't see how hera's mother died which
i was expecting
but sadly we do know that she's killed
shortly after this
and that it drives a big wedge between
hera and her father
back with rampart he realizes that he
has underestimated the batch
and he wants them on his side he gives
crosshair full permission to hunt them
down
and he sits there thinking over what he
would do personally i think that he'll
end up capturing the batch
they'll be taken before rampart and
crosstail will decide to free his
brothers
and do the right thing inspired by
hauser i would love it if they turn him
into an all-out villain but with his
show
you can kind of see how it's going to go
even though saying that i've got most of
my fan theories wrong
now as for the show and how i feel about
the series again another good one and i
like how each character progression
feels natural
instead of forced you could easily take
it that omega is force sensitive
but on the flip side of that you could
also think that she's as good as she is
because of who she was cloned from the
mandalorian revealed early on that
who had the force and this kind of took
away the attention from mando
and made everyone milk videos about him
i like how omega is a lot more subtle
than that
and though i don't think that she has
the force i still have fun watching
people argue over that
instead of whether kathleen kennedy has
been fired for the 50th time this year
the show has brought the focus back to
star wars and it's nice to just turn off
from the controversy and enjoy for what
it is
again another great episode and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it
so make sure you comment below and let
me know we're running a competition
right now
and giving away three mcu box sets on
the 30th of july
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we picked the
winners at random at the end of the
month
and the ones from the last competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
without the way thank you for sitting
through this i've been paul i'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]